is security and defense analyst
Professor Michael Clark it's great to
see you thanks for joining us on the
program what's going on do you think
it's hard to say it's clearly an act of
sabotage I mean these are three
explosions uh near the seabed that you
need a submarine to do that so this is
not some casual terrorist act it has to
be a government the only government that
could possibly gain from this in a
rather peculiar way is Russia none of
the European governments would would
want to do it so
um privately everyone is convinced this
is a Kremlin inspired piece of sabotage
which is a strategic own goal because
although it increases this the sense of
isolation that there will be no Russian
gas for Europe this winter it actually
destroys Russia's credibility completely
with European customers for the next
couple of generations why would they do
it to push up the cost of yes well the
the new pipeline that opened yesterday
was inaugurated yesterday between Norway
and Poland by Denmark runs across just
where these explosions occurred and so
my guess and I'm guessing is that the
Russians wanted to
um create insecurity that there may be
more of this in other words that that
European supplies which are not
generated from Russia might now be at
risk but it opens up a new front in the
world wouldn't it yeah well it means
that the the Ukrainian war is now going
to the Baltic which is not surprising in
one sense we we knew it would arrive in
the Baltic at some point and as Putin
gets more desperate it's opening up a
new insecurity so NATO I think will now
have to start being very careful about
Maritime Security in the Baltic and I
would expect to see that now
the EU have said that they will
retaliate if it's proven to be a Russian
intervention yes it's hard to say I mean
Ursula vanderlein always makes these
strong statements it's hard to see what
the EU as such could do
um I mean they can tighten sanctions
they could do more of what they're doing
now as and when the finger really does
point to Russia as I suspect it will in
in due course
um but the real response comes not
really from the EU but from NATO I mean
this will become a military issue in the
sense that NATO will have to look after
the security of the Baltic much more
carefully and they've got plans to do
that I mean in Britain we've been
talking about the um the vulnerability
of pipelines for a long time now for
some years and for undersea cables
because most of the undersea cables that
come across the Atlantic come into
Land's End and they go through the uh
through the area of the channel and the
Western approaches and so we've started
to deploy Naval forces to look after
those cables because we know that
they're vulnerable and so this this
um the battle to defend what's on the
seabed is been something that's been
developing over recent years and it's
now become I think or will become a
reality in the Baltic in the coming one
or two years what about what's on top of
the series speaking to the Lord Janet
yesterday and he was suggesting that he
wouldn't be resting comfortably he was
part of the Black Sea Fleet at the
moment
um no the Black Sea Fleet is now under
some pressure they lost the mosqueva
which was the flagship of course which
was attacked by the ukrainians and they
haven't been able to add to that because
they can't bring any more warships from
their Northern Fleet through the through
the Bosphorus because they're not
allowed to Turkey won't let them good
for them and so the Black Sea Fleet is
baked in sevastopol savastapol in Crimea
is now vulnerable to Ukrainian attacks
and the whole of the backs of most of
the Black Sea fleet has now been
deployed further eastwards in the Black
Sea so the western part of the Black Sea
around Odessa has become something of a
no-go area for the the Russian Black Sea
Fleet and you can see that pressure
building up again everywhere you look in
terms of Russia's war in Ukraine they're
running out of options they started off
with as it were the whole map to play
with and in every case they've been
frustrated the strategy has been
deflected they're not making progress
from a military point of view anywhere
because the Russians are saying they're
annexing land because they've got these
referenda we saw that happen
um more or less with Crimea although the
annex Crimea for very different reasons
back in 2014.
um what happens when the European Union
say no no I don't think so yeah well the
European nobody accepts these these
referendum results I mean they're
ridiculous they were set up within a
week and they just squeaked through with
98 and 97 that was a that was a close
one will knew that would happen nobody
takes it seriously at all
um and it just adds to the sense that
that um the Kremlin is living in a world
of its own now I mean Putin thinks he
gets some advantages from this because
he claims this is Russian territory
therefore they can send conscripts
straight there which they are beginning
to do the new round of conscription
begins on the 1st of October so within a
few days now another 130 000 conscripts
would be called in and they can now be
sent directly to those War zones because
those War zones are regarded by Russia
as Russian territory and it brings those
territories within the nuclear clear
doctrine of Russia which is to say they
would only use nuclear weapons to defend
their own territory all of that is saber
rattling it doesn't make a blind bit of
difference to the way the ukrainians
will fight all the way so far the West
is supporting Ukraine so it again it UPS
the ante it's a propaganda tactic from
Putin to say to his own people look you
know all these people 98 of them want to
be Russian so we've Annex the territory
I mean that's what he did in Crimea as
you say in 2014
um none of the rest of the world
believes it even his Chinese friends
don't believe it it is something that
only he seems to believe yeah and yet
though Crimea is still part of Russian
territory and these troops aren't the
troops that are going immediately now to
Ukraine these new conscripts some of
them with no training whatsoever some of
them with two or three weeks with no
equipment I was looking at some material
last night where they were being told
get hold of sanitary pads from your
wives and your mothers because they're
the best we've got for bandages because
they will absorb blood bring your bring
their first aid kits out of your cars we
can't give you any these people are
being sent with literally nothing but a
uniform and a rifle to the front now
they're not going to be there to fight
the Russians are defending they're
digging in right round the front and so
if they bring in these new conscripts
just to hold a piece of front which is
easier than really fighting then they
can release some of the troops who've
been there for eight months without a
break to rotate them get them back into
some areas where they can reorganize
them give them a bit of rest and so on
so the the logic for bringing these new
completely untrained recruits to the
front is to take experienced soldiers
away from the front so they can
reorganize for what will be I'm fairly
sure a big Russian counter-offensive
next year after the winter they're
digging in for the winter when the
weather starts to break again in
February March then we can expect the
Russians to push then to a really big
probably a nationwide offensive and the
ukrainians and the West will have to be
ready for that just a final thought
would Ukraine not have expected Europe
and the West to have stepped in to try
to stop these referenda going ahead uh
no the there's nothing you can do about
the referendum there's nothing the West
can do without getting directly involved
so in a way what the West has done is
all it can do is to say this is
ridiculous we don't accept these things
they make no real difference and the War
I mean you know this war will be
determined not by the politics of
maneuver but by the maneuver that goes
on on the ground this ultimately this
comes down to heavy metal and people who
are prepared to fight